Okay, I'm going to step you now through
the mechanics of short selling.
Pay attention because it's complicated.
[LAUGH]
Okay,
let's imagine the following scenario.
You want to take a short
position in IBM, and
IBM is currently selling at $100.
That's the current market price.
Joe holds 100 shares of IBM.
He likes IBM, he wants to hold onto it.
But he's willing to lend
you those shares of IBM.
In fact, Joe's broker will
take care of that for him.
He may not even know that
he's lending you the shares.
Let's suppose Lisa thinks that IBM is
going to go up and she wants to buy IBM.
So you want to sell IBM short.
You don't own any shares of it.
Lisa wants to buy IBM.
She thinks it's going to go up.
So here's what happens.
You borrow that 100 shares from Joe.
Now that you have those shares, you
can turn around and sell them to Lisa.
And in exchange for
those 100 shares that you gave Lisa,
she gives you 100 times $100,
or $10,000.
So let me recap that.
You want to sell IBM short.
Joe has 100 shares of IBM.
Lisa wants to buy IBM.
So you borrow those 100 shares from Joe.
You immediately turn around and
sell them to Lisa, and you get $10,000.
The result of this transaction,
after everything settles,
is you have $10,000 in your account but
you owe Joe 100 shares of stock.
And of course,
Lisa has 100 shares of stock and so on.
Now the problem sort of arises here that
Joe may decide he wants
his 100 shares back.
What you'll have to do is go
buy them from someone and
then give them back to Joe.
But let's deal with that
a little bit later.